across the Lagoon from the famed sites
of Old Venice a scene of Carnage
firefighters working through the night
to recover bodies and put out
Flames this bus was carrying foreign
tourists to a campsite on the mainland
it plunged from an overpass and then
burst into
flames bus went off the road at a height
of more than 10 m it's a battery powered
electric bus so it caught fire and they
found the people inside the bus engulfed
in flames the scene that the firemen had
to deal with was really difficult really
bad more than 20 people were killed
including two children among the dead
are ukrainians a German and the Italian
bus driver several others were injured
some in serious
condition the mayor of Venice described
the scene as apocalyptic and declared
the city in a state of mourning the
Italian Prime Minister expressed her
profound
condolences the cause of the accident
remains unclear the bus was new and that
stretch of road hasn't been an issue in
the past Italy's public prosecutor has
launched an investigation as families
across Europe wait for
answers Alexander buers Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news news from
Al
jazer